also first from our eight news now
i-team for the first time we're seeing
the aftermath inside that hookah lounge
where one man died and 13 others were
injured the i-team's david charn is here
now with the images david kirsten as the
i-team first told you police suspect
there were as many as five shooters
involved in this mass shooting inside
this hookah lounge these new crime scene
photos show what investigators
documented that morning in late february
you can see the flipped furniture debris
those evidence markers from where
officers found bullet casings detectives
say the shootout began in this vip area
with several couches tables and booths
one man was killed 13 others hurt in the
shooting it happened during a birthday
party and as we told you county
officials say the lounge was serving
alcohol in hookah and operating as a
nightclub all without the proper
licenses 44-year-old lee wilson facing a
charge of murder and several counts of
attempted murder police have not named
any other suspects only saying publicly
that other people were involved
wilson due back in court in july we have
posted all these photos from that lounge
on eight newsnow dot com and inside our
app i'm david sharon is live local now